the Nevada Psychiatric association
mental health conference has been
happening through this week and today's
topic the rising rate of Overdose deaths
Madison Kimbrough is live in our
Newsroom tonight with what medical
experts and those in recovery are saying
Madison yes opioid use has become an
epidemic and here locally the Southern
Nevada Health District reporting over a
hundred fentanyl deaths in just a
six-month Span in 2022.
and we're getting people that are coming
in they're talking choices fentanyl
which is really scary because you know
you could take what a penny size right
and it it can kill you George gatsky CEO
of desert hope treatment center sharing
with us what he has seen at his facility
and as a recovering addict himself who
has been clean for 31 years he feels
these drugs have not only become
stronger but more readily accessible to
the masses back in the day when I got
clean there wasn't fentanyl or these
it's almost like the opioids drugs or
you know Oxycontin oxycodone fentanyl
these are just kidding and more and more
powerful and we're seeing the overdose
rate rise so you know us treatment
centers our safety and you know concerns
of taking care of people or we've had to
raise the bar this week the annual
Nevada Psychiatric Association
conference took place on the Strip
bringing psychiatrists and medical
experts together to talk about mental
health and ways to combat dangerous drug
use like a new proposed state bill that
is already been enacted in some states
would allow people to use illegal
injectable drugs safely at designated
locations to keep them from overdosing
known as safe injection sites but as the
former assistant Secretary of Health and
Human Services for mental health and
substance explains any type of drug use
is unsafe no matter where you do it
period what we've seen is flooding into
the country of counterfeit pills that
have fentanyl
street drugs Street opioids they have no
tolerance at all to opioids so if they
get a drug that has the stimulant but
also has fentanyl in it they're at very
high risk for overdose and death
in recent years fentanyl strips have
been designed to detect the drug in
Street bought opiates and also methadone
clinics are available to those who are
struggling with addiction methadone
being the medication used to treat
opioid use disorder in The Newsroom
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now
[Applause]